MAD TOYS
Wouah le Super Sonic Shark Road de l'Emmental !
Construis ton circuit et éclate toi avec des virages démentiels.
MAD TOYS
Mets le feu aux routes pour plus de puissance,
Et atteins des vitesses hallucinantes
MAD TOYS
Waouh le Super Sonic Shark Road de l'Emmental provoque des brûlures au 3 ème degré !
Oh Super !
Tout les matins, moi Pierre Renard
Je vais à la rencontre des petits producteurs.
Des amoureux de la terre,
des passionnés de culture et de travail bien fait.
Chaque jour je m'efforce de choisir les plus beaux légumes,
Et ces légumes...
Et ben je les garde pour moi !
Et pour vous je vais chercher des légumes de merde,
cultivé par des pauvres cons, intoxiqués aux pesticides.
Et ces légumes dégueux j'les fous dans les soupes et vous vous faites pas la différence
parce que vous y connaissez rien en soupe.
Les soupes Pierre Renard, vous faites pas la différence, car vous y connaissez rien en soupe.
LUNETTES !
Elles corrigent ta vision lorsque ta vue baisse !
Avec leur méga paire de verre,
leur monture de folie !
Tes lunettes vont pulvériser la myopie !
C'est trop bien !
LUNETTES !
Et si tes lunettes sont cassées,
Oh non !
WAOUH ! Ton opticien t'offre une deuxième paire !
Une troisième ! Une quatrième !
HAHAHAHAHA
C'est des lunettes !
Mercurothrome, le pansement des héros !
Ben, bof quand même !
Je me suis pris une balle dans le coeur mon gars !
Mercurotrome, le pansement des héros !
J'essaie, j'essaie, mais ça n'adhère pas ton truc !
Regarde !
Mercurotrome le pansement des héros.
Je suis sûr que c'est en train de s'infecter là !
Ça gicle, ça gicle vous avez vu !
Non, faut appeler une ambulance !
Merchurotrome le pansement des héros !
Il fait froid d'un coup non ?
C'est moi où il fait froid d'un coup ?
Mercurotrome, le pansement des héros !
Ça va pas servir oui... Il est mort.
LES FROMAGES DE NOS REGIONS !
Waouh ! Des produits laitiers à dévorer !
Régale-toi en fin de repas à la vitesse de la lumière !
Lors d'une raclette démentielle fais tout fondre par la puissance du feu !
Déguste-les en faisant des combinaisons infinies !
LE FROMAGE DE NOS REGIONS !